.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Könnten Sie mal kurz zusammenfassen,
was Ihre Hauptaussage sein soll?
Vor vielen Jahrtausenden,
als unsere Vorfahren
Steinzeitleute waren,
landeten mal Ausserirdische.
Unsere Vorfahren
verstanden das nicht.
Sie hatten
keine Ahnung von Technologie
und meinten irrtümlicherweise,
das seien Götter.
Mit dieser These
wurde Erich von Däniken
zu einem der erfolgreichsten
Sachbuchautoren der Welt,
aber auch
zu einem der umstrittensten.
(Mann) Die Methode, die er anwendet,
um Fragen zu beantworten,
funktioniert erstens Mal nicht.
Und zweitens haben wir viel Evidenz,
viele Daten und Beweise -
aus der Archäologie z.B. -,
die gegen seine Thesen sprechen.
Was macht diesen Mann für manche
Menschen trotzdem so faszinierend?
Noch heute folgen seine Anhänger
dem 88-Jährigen rund um den Globus.
Ich will das Phänomen
Erich von Däniken
aus nächster Nähe erleben
und schliesse mich
einer von ihm geführten Reise an.
Auch wenn ich mich damit
auf dünnes Eis begebe.
Der Typ ist vom Schweizer Fernsehen.
Das ist immer dasselbe.
Er hat mir gesagt,
er könne nur kritisch sein.
Die haben alle ...
Die sind alle gaga hier.
Mir wird schnell klar: Das wird
keine ganz alltägliche Reise.
Eine Weste.
- What for?
Ich kann schwimmen.
Vor der Recherche zu diesem Film
wusste ich nichts über ihn.
Doch selten hat eine Filmidee von mir
solch kontroverse Reaktionen
hervorgerufen.
Von "Super, dass du das machst,
sei aber offen"
bis "So einem Mann
darf man doch keine Bühne bieten"
war alles dabei.
Wir werden jetzt
eine Woche in Malta sein.
Zuerst möchte ich wissen,
wer hier Wiederholungstäter ist.
Hebt die Hand.
Hm? Hm?
Zwei Drittel.
Dann muss ich nichts mehr sagen.
Ihr wisst alles.
Und du? Du bist der Fernsehmann.
- Ich bin Dave
und komme aus Süddeutschland,
vom Bodensee.
Ich arbeite in Zürich
fürs Schweizer Fernsehen
und mache ein Porträt
über Erich von Däniken.- Okay.
Ich muss euch noch etwas sagen.
Etwas, das mir ein Anliegen ist:
Jeder hier im Raum ist einzigartig.
Wir leben in einer Welt, in der man
uns alle vergemeinschaften will.
Wir sollen alle gleich sein.
Woke.
Wer nicht gleicher Meinung ist,
wird ausgeschieden, weggeschmissen.
Wir sind weder ein politischer
Verein, noch eine religiöse Sekte.
Wir haben nichts
mit Politik oder Religion zu tun.
Wir sind hier, weil uns die Rätsel
auf dieser Insel interessieren.
Die Rätsel dieser Welt
haben Erich von Däniken
schon in jungen Jahren fasziniert.
Zwar brachte er es in der Gastro-
nomiebranche bis zum Hoteldirektor,
doch seine Interessen
waren schon damals andere.
Seit über 60 Jahren reist er
rund um den Erdball, um zu beweisen,
dass einst Ausserirdische hier waren.
1969 gelang ihm mit seinem
ersten Buch ein Weltbestseller.
Die Dänikitis brach aus,
und bis heute verkaufte er nach
eigenen Angaben rund 75 Mio. Bücher.
Unsere Maltareise
beginnt ganz irdisch:
Die Blaue Grotte
ist Touristenpflichtprogramm.
Ha. Hey, NASA.
Very good.
Give me your hand quickly.
Gott, ist das ein Scheissdreck.
Am besten gleich hinsetzen.
Wir haben es geschafft.
Jesses Gott, ist das ein Blödsinn.
Eine Weste.
- What for?
Ich kann schwimmen.
Was soll der Scheiss?
This is ridiculous, this here.
All this stupid stuff.
Verdammt noch mal.
Never again Malta.
Sie sind jetzt 88. Wie lange
wollen Sie solche Reisen noch machen?
Solange es mir Spass macht.
Malta ist eine kurze Reise.
Es ist nicht in den hohen Bergen.
Das macht noch Spass.
Wie viele solche Reisen
machen Sie pro Jahr?
Meistens drei.
Aber ich bin auch unabhängig
von Gruppen dauernd unterwegs.
Ich halte sehr viele Vorträge
in den USA.
Wenn ich Signierstunden habe,
gibt es oft
eine Schlange von einigen 100 m.
Alle Menschen,
die zu mir kommen, sagen:
"Mr von Däniken,
you changed my life."
Das macht mich irgendwie stolz.
Ich habe ihr Denken verändert.
* Sanfte Musik *
Solche Vorschriften und Regeln,
wie z.B. die Schwimmwesten,
sind anscheinend nicht so Ihres.
- Ja.
Überhaupt nicht.
Ich kann ja schwimmen.
Was soll der Unsinn?
Ich verstehe das für Nichtschwimmer.
Waren Sie schon immer so rebellisch?
- Klar.
Ich habe einen eigenen Verstand.
Ich mag nicht,
dass andere für mich denken.
Sie waren in Ihrer Jugend
an einer Jesuitenschule.
Wie kam es dazu?
- Ich war ein Halunke.
Ich stellte alles Mögliche an,
zettelte Schlägereien an ...
Ich war der Rädelsführer und stahl
auch kleine Dinge in der Gang.
Mein Vater, ein wunderbarer Mann,
fand, ich müsse ins Internat.
Also steckte man mich
in eine Jesuitenschule.
Dort fing das alles an
mit den Ausserirdischen.
Mit den Religionszweifeln
in der Schule.
Nicht nur in der Bibel, sondern
in allen alten, heiligen Schriften
stiegen sog. Götter, Wesen,
hernieder.
Und die Menschen
meinten irrtümlicherweise,
das seien Götter.
Warum ist es Ihnen so wichtig, diese
Botschaft unter die Leute zu bringen?
Weil wir Menschen
bescheidener werden müssen.
Wir bilden uns ein,
die Grössten zu sein.
Die Religion sagt,
der liebe Gott habe uns
als Ikone der Schöpfung gemacht.
Die Wissenschaft sagt, alles sei
Evolution, Mutation und Selektion.
Wir seien die Spitze.
Beide denken,
es gäbe nichts Tolleres als uns.
Wir sollten lernen,
bescheidener zu werden.
Da draussen wimmelt es
von ausserirdischen Lebensformen.
Eines Tages werden sie sich zeigen.
Da will man
den Götterschock vermeiden.
Die Menschen
sollen keine Angst haben.
Sie werden kommen.
Nein, sie sind schon hier.
Wie kommen Sie darauf?
- Professor Doktor Haim Eshed
war 20 Jahre lang der Chef
der israelischen Weltraumbehörde.
Er sagte:
"Ausserirdische sind unter uns."
Es gebe Vereinbarungen mit ihnen.
Kanadas Ex-Verteidigungsminister
Mr Paul Hellyer -
der ist inzwischen gestorben -
sagte mehrmals:
"Ausserirdische sind unter uns."
"Wir könnten ihnen
auf der Strasse begegnen."
"Man würde es nicht merken."
Der rätselhafte Teil der Reise
beginnt bei den Karrenspuren,
den sog. Cart Ruts.
Vorsicht, hier wird es stufig.
Ich gehe nicht nach hinten.
Ich bleibe hier. Ist mir zu blöd.
Überall sind die Spuren im Boden.
Wir haben gemessen,
wie tief sie sind: 83 cm.
In einer sehr engen Kurve.
Da kommt kein Rad durch.
Und kein Schwein weiss, was es ist.
Karrenspuren nicht:
Die Spurbreiten ändern dauernd.
Hier sieht man es am besten, aber
das zieht sich über die ganze Insel.
Was denken Sie, was es sein könnte?
- Keine Ahnung.
Es gibt verschiedenste wissen-
schaftliche Erklärungsansätze dafür,
was die Cart Ruts einmal waren.
Was ich nachlesen konnte, ergab aber,
dass noch keine Theorie
der Weisheit letzter Schluss sei.
Das lädt ein zum Spekulieren.
Es muss alles warm gewesen sein.
Wenn man sich das anschaut:
Das sieht aufgeschäumt aus.
Ich kann es nicht erklären,
aber es sieht so ...
(Frau) Es sieht schon so aus,
als ob etwas
daran entlanggeschrammt wäre.
Schon wegen dieser scharfen Kante.
(Mann) Es sieht
nach mehreren Versuchen aus.
Hier fuhr ein Fahrzeug hoch.
Es versuchte, hier rüberzufahren,
kam aber nicht hoch.
Dann versuchte es das hier.
So sieht es aus.
Was ist das Faszinierende
an einer solchen Reise?
(Frau)
Die Gruppendynamik, der Austausch
und dieses Zusammensein
von Gleichgesinnten.
Das Fachsimpeln über diese Rätsel.
- Genau.
Wenn man einfach ganz ...
... unbedarft rangeht
und nur den logischen
Menschenverstand braucht,
kommt man automatisch zum Schluss,
dass etwas nicht stimmen kann.
Das ist das Spannende.
Da die Lösungen zu suchen
und zu überlegen.
Wenn das, was einem erzählt wird,
nicht stimmt,
was war es denn dann?
"Was einem erzählt wird" -
also, was die Wissenschaft erzählt?
Ja, was der Mainstream halt erzählt.
Oder was man in der Schule
oder den Wissenschaftsbüchern
zu lesen und hören kriegt.
Das geht irgendwie
einfach nicht auf.
Sind Sie zum ersten Mal hier?
- In Malta, ja.
Ja? Und ansonsten
auf einer Däniken-Reise?
Zum fünften Mal.
- Zum fünften Mal?
Griechenland, Ägypten, Mittelamerika
und letztes Jahr Türkei.
Man kann das greifen,
was man in den Büchern liest.
Man sieht das mal wirklich.
Das ist ein ganz anderer Eindruck.
Ich halte ihn
für eine Kapazität auf dem Gebiet.
Es geht darum,
Fragen zu den ungelösten Rätseln
der Menschheit zu stellen.
Er ist quasi
ein Denklehrer für mich.
Okay.
- Für meine kleine Birne.
Wir waren heute da draussen:
Cart Ruts.
Was, liebe Gäste, liebe Freunde,
ist das?
Gebt mir die Antwort.
Ich habe keine.
Ihr seid die intelligente Spezies
in diesem Hotel.
* Lachen *
Von euren Gehirnen
erwarte ich Lösungen und Antworten.
Was waren diese Cart Ruts?
Wer hat die gemacht? Und wozu?
Wann? Was? Bitte.
Nur los.
Legt alle Gedanken auf den Tisch.
(Frau)
Alles würde viel einfacher aufgehen,
wenn wir akzeptieren würden,
dass es Wesen gab,
die einfach andere Kräfte hatten.
Es müssen ja nicht Ausserirdische
gewesen sein in dem Moment,
sondern eben ein Menschengeschlecht,
das halt grösser war.
- Durchaus möglich. Ja, absolut.
Vielleicht
war es ein Militäreinsatz.
Also, in der weit
zurückliegenden Vergangenheit.
Mit grossen Fahrzeugen.
Noch mehr Ideen? Hier? Ja.
Wenn ich das
nur vom Gefühl her empfunden habe,
fühle ich das sehr brutal.
Als ob da
etwas Brutales passiert wäre.
Aber das kann verrückt sein.
Das muss nicht stimmen.
Warum nicht?
Die Legende sagt ja, das sei
eine Insel der Riesen gewesen.
Und die Riesen
seien die Söhne der Götter gewesen,
der Ausserirdischen, die noch
das Wissen ihrer Väter hatten.
Vielleicht hatten sie
eine Technologie,
von der wir keine Ahnung haben.
Wir suchen Karrenspuren
und liegen total falsch.
Zu den Cart Ruts habe ich im Internet
ein altes Video von Ihnen gefunden,
in dem Sie spekulieren, es könnten
Landeversuche von Ufos gewesen sein.
Erinnern Sie sich daran?
- Das ist nicht von von Däniken.
Darüber habe ich mich so aufgeregt.
Das war die Sendung eines deutschen
oder amerikanischen Senders,
und die haben das dahergebracht.
Ich fand das komplett lächerlich.
- Aber Sie haben anmoderiert.
Aber nicht das, was man da sah.
Vielleicht
sagte ich was zu den Cart Ruts
und dann kam das Fernsehteam
oder wer auch immer
und machte das daraus.
Es ging darum,
Herr von Däniken und seine Ansichten
lächerlich zu machen.
Ein Vergleich fällt mir ein:
Unsere Astronauten
liessen Spuren auf dem Mond zurück.
Dort oben
fuhr sogar ein Mondauto rum.
Malta besteht aus Kalkstein.
Wenn der feucht ist, ist er weich.
Haben vielleicht Ufos
im Walzertakt den Boden berührt?
Nach über 60 Jahren voller Bücher,
Fernsehsendungen und Vorträgen
kann man schon mal etwas vergessen.
Mir ist aufgefallen,
dass Erich von Däniken -
zumindest auf unserer Reise -
mehr Fragen stellt,
als Antworten zu geben.
Das nächste der drei
von Dänikeschen Superrätsel auf Malta
sind die megalithischen Tempel.
Schau, die Kleinen sind vorne.
Die Kleinen sind vorne.
In Arabien sagt man "Bakschisch".
Bakschisch und dann ist es gut hier.
Es geht um megalithische Tempel.
Gestern habe ich erklärt,
dass "megalithos" Griechisch sei.
"Mega" heisst "gross".
Die Jungen sagen "megageil".
"Mega" - "gross",
"lithos" ist "der Stein".
Man meint damit Gesellschaften,
die grosse Steine gebaut haben.
Das ist nicht datierbar.
Es gibt megalithische Bauten,
die 2000 v. Chr. gebaut wurden,
andere 5000 v. Chr.
Hier sprechen sie offiziell
von rund 3500 v. Chr.
Ich glaube kein Wort davon.
Die Geschichte ist viel älter.
Was es war,
wer gebaut hat und warum hier ...
Auf Malta gibt es 28 dieser Dinger.
Wir haben keine Ahnung.
Wir schwimmen wieder mal.
Geht mal rein.
Wir sprechen
immer von der Steinzeit. Ja ...
Wie kommen Sie auf die Idee,
dass das hier älter ist,
als die Geschichtswissenschaft sagt?
In mehr oder weniger
historischen Zeiten,
so 2000 v. Chr., wüssten wir davon.
Wir hätten Überlieferungen.
Es gibt keine.
Das war immer schon da.
Ich habe sowieso immer die Frage:
Warum?
Nicht nur hier, bei allen
sog. megalithischen Tempeln.
Wenn man sich
Steinzeitleute vorstellt ...
In unserer evolutionären Vorstellung
sind das technologisch Primitive.
Sie hatten einfache Mittel.
Und jetzt bist du hier.
Die müssen mit Rollen oder Holz,
das es kaum gibt,
riesige Steine transportiert haben,
um zu solchen komplexen ...
Erst kommt die Planung ...
Und nicht für einen, sondern für 28.
Mir fehlt der Sinn, die Logik.
Ich bin immer der Meinung, unsere
Vorfahren waren keine Dummchen.
Das waren hochintelligente Leute.
Die Tempel beweisen das.
Die waren nicht primitiv.
Es steckt etwas anderes dahinter,
aber wir kommen nicht drauf.
Ich wünsche mir eine Zeitmaschine.
Aber das Traurige ist:
Wenn ich eine Zeitmaschine hätte,
genau beobachten könnte, wie es war,
und dann zurückkäme,
würden alle sagen:
"Hallo? Stimmt nicht."
Dann wären Sie ja vielleicht
in einem Wandbild verewigt.
Nein, nein. Nein.
Nach so viel Rätselraten
steht mir der Sinn nach Wissenschaft.
Malta ist ein sehr spezieller Ort.
Es gibt 28 Tempel, die Cart Ruts ...
Die Cart Ruts
sind praktisch überall.
Das scheint eine grosse Anzahl
an Tempeln zu sein
für so eine kleine Insel.
- Yes, yes.
Ja, und das ist
ein grosses Fragezeichen für uns.
Eine grosse Herausforderung.
Wir haben Siedlungen gesucht,
in denen die Tempelbauer
gelebt haben müssen.
Eine der Begründungen dafür,
warum wir keine
oder nur wenige Belege
für solch eine Architektur haben:
Sie waren wohl zufrieden damit,
für sich selbst
sehr dünne Strukturen zu bauen -
aus Lehmziegeln
oder wasserhaltigem Material,
welches dazu neigt,
innerhalb weniger Jahre
zu bröckeln und zu verschwinden.
Wir glauben, dass die Tempel in der
Nähe von solchen Siedlungen waren.
Aber diese Siedlungen
verschwanden spurlos.
Ich gebe zu:
Das ist keine glückliche Situation.
Aber bis wir
eine weitere schlüssige Erklärung
durch wissenschaftliche
Untersuchungen haben,
müssen wir uns damit zufriedengeben.
Das hatte ich mir
doch etwas eindeutiger erhofft.
Zumindest bei den Cart Ruts
war sich Professor Bonanno
dann doch ziemlich sicher.
Er fand Häufungen von Karrenspuren
neben Steinbrüchen aus römischer Zeit
und Häufungen
rund um Maltas damalige Hauptstädte.
Die damals üblichen
grossen Metallräder
der mit Steinen beladene Karren
hätten die Spuren in den
relativ weichen Untergrund gemacht.
Der Vater der maltesischen
Geschichtsschreibung,
ein gewisser
Giovanni Francesco Abela,
der ein Buch über die Geschichte
Maltas veröffentlichte,
untersuchte die Cart Ruts,
die ins Meer führen.
Er deutete an,
dass Malta tatsächlich schon damals
Stein aus den Steinbrüchen
per Schiff ins Ausland exportierte.
Das dritte Mysterium Maltas
ist UNESCO-Kulturerbe
und wurde mir
als besonders rätselhaft angekündigt.
Ins Hypogäum dürfen
immer nur zehn Personen gleichzeitig:
Zu fragil ist das Klima im
dreistöckigen unterirdischen Tempel.
Zudem ist das Filmen leider verboten.
Ab 3800 v. Chr. fanden hier Menschen
ihre letzte Ruhe.
Beeindruckend,
dass all diese Grabkammern
in einer Zeit
aus dem Fels gekratzt wurden,
als es noch
keine Metallwerkzeuge gab.
(Mann) Das wurde mit irgendwelchen
technischen Geräten hergestellt.
Es kann mir keiner erzählen, dass
das mit Steinen rausgeklopft wurde.
(Mann) Als die Führerin sagte,
das hätten sie mit ...
Was hat sie gesagt? Mit prongs ...
Mit Geweihen.
- Die seien da reingesteckt worden.
Das erschien mir ziemlich abstrus.
Ich war mit Leuten unterwegs,
die sich sicher waren,
man könnte das nie
so präzise aus dem Fels schnitzen
ohne Metallwerkzeuge
oder moderne Technik.
Sie meinen, Leute sagen,
das wäre unmöglich?
Wenn Sie sich mal
die Osterinsel anschauen würden,
Rapa Nui:
Dort haben Anthropologen
mit eigenen Augen gesehen,
wie Ureinwohner
diese riesigen, 5 m hohen Statuen
aus noch härterem Stein schnitzen,
mit ganz einfachen Hämmern.
Es ist nicht korrekt zu sagen,
das sei unmöglich.
Was man braucht,
ist Geduld und Zeit.
Und Zeit gab es genug
in prähistorischen Zeiten.
In diesem Kreis
werfen wir Fragen auf.
Wir haben keine Antworten.
Hier gibt es keine Rechthaber,
die sagen, dass es definitiv so war.
Das ist super.
Die andere Seite macht uns glauben,
dass es so war.
Und das stimmt nicht.
Wir haben Fragen.
Sie zitieren renommierte Leute,
die Ihre These untermauern.
Sie sagen,
Sie würden nur Fragen stellen,
geben aber keine Antworten.
Damit macht man sich
auch unangreifbar,
wenn man nur fragt
und keine konkreten Antworten gibt.
Und Sie glauben,
uns würde etwas verschwiegen.
Das sind drei klassische Motive,
die mittlerweile viele
Verschwörungstheoretiker benutzen,
um ihre Botschaften zu verbreiten.
Wer verschweigt uns etwas?
- Die Wissenschaft und die Religion.
Nicht, weil sie bösartig sind.
Alle Wissenschaftler, die ich kenne,
sind blitzgescheite,
vernünftige Leute.
Humorvoll, geistreich, integer.
Aber sie befassen sich
mit einem bestimmten Thema nicht.
Für sie ist dieses Thema lächerlich.
Ihre Ansicht ist falsch.
Der Zeitgeist wird sich ändern.
Und zwar zu unseren Gunsten.
Was ist der Zeitgeist?
Den Zeitgeist
gab es vor Jahrtausenden,
den Zeitgeist gibt es gestern,
den Zeitgeist gibt es heute,
den Zeitgeist gibt es morgen.
Der Zeitgeist
ist die gerade herrschende Vernunft.
Was eine Mehrheit glaubt, sei so,
ist vernünftig.
Wer gegen den Zeitgeist geht,
wird als unvernünftig abgetan.
Seid unvernünftig!
Der Zeitgeist zurzeit
verkündet uns Gleichmacherei.
Der Zeitgeist
verkündet unserer Jugend
Gleichgeschlechtlichkeit,
Schwulerei, Homosexualität ...
Ich habe nichts dagegen.
Schwul, homo - alles normal.
Aber nein,
Männer sollen Frauen sein,
Frauen haben gefälligst
einen Penis zu haben,
Männer eine Vagina - alles bekloppt.
Sie haben gestern Ihre
abendliche Diskussionsveranstaltung
mit
einer ziemlich radikalen Äusserung
hinsichtlich
Transgendermenschen eröffnet.
Das hat mich überrascht.
Sie sagten ja schon oft,
Sie seien unpolitisch.
Kann es sein,
dass Sie in einem Alter sind,
wo Sie mit dem Zeitgeist
nicht mehr Schritt halten?- Möglich.
Es gibt vielleicht
den sog. Altersstarrsinn.
Aber in meinem Falle
sehe ich das nicht.
Wobei das natürlich jeder
bei sich nicht sieht.
Ich wollte mich noch verabschieden.
Wir sind ab morgen früh weg.
Vielen Dank, dass wir so offen
und herzlich aufgenommen wurden.
Stopp, stopp.
Der Typ ist vom Schweizer Fernsehen.
Das ist immer dasselbe.
Er hat mir gesagt,
er könne nur kritisch sein.
Die haben alle ...
Die sind alle gaga hier.
Immerhin ...
Ich sage auch noch ein Schlusswort.
Immerhin gibt es jetzt
einen Film beim Schweizer Fernsehen.
Als ich Sie
zum ersten Mal getroffen habe,
sagten Sie zu mir, Journalisten
hätten Angst sich zu blamieren.
Ich habe keine Angst davor.
Ich mache den Film.
Danke dir. Du hast meinen Respekt.
Der Mann heisst Da... Dave.
David. David.
Und er sieht nicht nur
sympathisch aus, er ist es auch.
* Lachen *
Warten Sie,
bis Sie den Film gesehen haben.
* Lachen *
In der Schweiz versuche ich,
das Erlebte einzuordnen.
An der Kantonsschule Uster
treffe ich einen der bekanntesten
Experten für Verschwörungstheorien.
Frage in die Runde:
Kennt jemand von euch
Herr von Däniken?
Ein paar Leute kennen ihn.
Die älteren Semester noch eher.
Erich von Däniken
hat vor Jahrzehnten begonnen,
sich der Frage "Sind wir allein?"
zu widmen.
1968 veröffentlichte er das Buch
mit dem Titel
"Erinnerungen an die Zukunft".
Das ist ein Buch, das mich
in meiner Jugend sehr geprägt hat.
Es wurde
ein internationaler Bestseller.
In diesem Buch
stellt er die These auf,
wir seien nicht nur nicht allein,
wir seien schon besucht worden.
Auch jetzt in diesem Moment
werden wir von Ausserirdischen
von oben beobachtet.
Die sind immer da
und haben uns nie verlassen.
Aber ihre Technologie
ist leider so fortschrittlich,
dass wir sie
weder sehen noch messen können.
Blöderweise
kann man es nicht beweisen.
Das ist einfach
gute Science-Fiction.
Extrem packend.
Sind die einfachen Theorien
einfach spannender
als die langweilige Wissenschaft?
Menschen sind dazu gemacht,
Geschichten wahrzunehmen.
Wir wollen Geschichten hören.
Geschichten erklären uns die Welt.
Komplexe Erklärungen mit Grautönen
und verschiedenen Standpunkten
sind anstrengend.
Ich hatte das Gefühl, dass Erich von
Dänikens Theorien eher harmlos seien.
Gibt es harmlose und weniger harmlose
Verschwörungstheorien?
Inhaltlich
kann man durchaus unterscheiden.
Erich von Däniken behauptet nichts,
was unmittelbar zu Gewalt aufruft.
Indirekt aber
sind auch seine Theorien
eine Einstiegsrampe in die
Unvernunft, in irrationales Denken.
Man setzt sich eine Brille auf
und sieht plötzlich überall
Verschwörungen
und alternative Wahrheiten.
Man ist nicht mehr empfänglich für
z.B. wissenschaftliche Argumente.
Das ist Ihnen passiert,
Sie rutschten immer tiefer rein.
Was hat das mit Ihnen gemacht?
Es gab mir paradoxerweise
ein Gefühl der Überlegenheit.
Ich hatte Wissen darüber,
wie die Welt wirklich funktioniert.
Und alle anderen, die Schlafschafe,
hatten keine Ahnung.
Das ist ein schönes Gefühl.
Okay.
Und das Argument, man solle so einem
keine öffentliche Bühne bieten?
Man kann sagen, von Däniken solle
keine öffentliche Bühne erhalten.
Aber er hat Dutzende Millionen
von Büchern verkauft.
Er  h a t  ein grosses Publikum,
er  h a t  Einfluss.
Seine Ideen werden immer noch
weltweit diskutiert.
Dieser Diskussion
sollte man sich auch auf
der "Gegenseite" nicht entziehen.
Sie glauben jedenfalls
felsenfest daran.
Sie haben nicht einfach gemerkt,
dass sich damit
gut Bücher verkaufen lassen.
Ich glaube nicht daran,
ich weiss es.
Können Sie mir
einen schlagenden Beweis zeigen?
Oh ja.
Da gibt es
die alten heiligen Schriften,
z.B. "Das Buch Henoch".
Vor der Flut, vor Jahrtausenden,
wurde Henoch von Ausserirdischen
mitgenommen und erzogen.
U.a. brachten sie ihm das bei:
"Menschensohn, schau mal raus."
"Siehst du das kleine Licht dort?"
"Ihr Menschen nennt das Mond.
Der hat kein eigenes Licht."
"Er bezieht sein Licht
von der Sonne."
Diese Botschaft konnte vor
Jahrtausenden kein Mensch wissen.
Niemand wusste, dass der Mond
sein Licht von der Sonne bezieht.
"Das Buch Henoch"
muss für so einiges herhalten.
Auch die Flache-Erde-Bewegung will
einige Textstellen gefunden haben,
die belegen,
dass die Erde eine Scheibe sei.
Ich habe eine Gegenthese
zu "Das Buch Henoch".
Wenn sie in dieser frühen Zeit
von Ausserirdischen
unterwiesen worden wären,
müssten sie wissen,
dass die Erde keine Scheibe ist.
Selbstverständlich wissen die das.
"Das Buch Henoch" ist
ein riesiges Konglomerat geworden.
Es wurde x-mal umgeschrieben.
Über die Jahrhunderte
kam viel Unsinn dazu.
Von der Wissenschaft
wird seit den 70er-Jahren kritisiert,
dass Erich von Däniken Bilder,
Bauwerke, Kunstwerke und Texte
völlig losgelöst vom historischen und
kulturellen Kontext interpretiert,
der für ihr Verständnis
jedoch zwingend nötig sei.
In seiner Heimat hat ihm das
anscheinend nicht geschadet.
Im malerischen Beatenberg
lebt er mit seiner Frau Elisabeth,
die er vor 66 Jahren heiratete
und mit der er eine Tochter hat.
Seine Lebensgeschichte
kann man hier erwandern.
Ich mache einen Film
über Erich von Däniken
und ich muss sagen -
seine Theorien mal beiseite:
Es ist erstaunlich zu beobachten,
wie viel Energie
es einem Menschen geben kann,
wenn er fest an eine Idee glaubt.
Eines seiner Grossprojekte
steht seit 2003 in Interlaken:
der Mystery Park -
die Rätsel dieser Erde zum Anfassen.
Sechs Jahre
liefen hier nur Däniken-Shows.
2009 wurde er zum JungfrauPark
und die sieben Rätsel wurden im
Wechsel mit anderen Events gezeigt.
Seit 2021 ist er geschlossen.
Der Park
ist jetzt komplett geschlossen, oder?
Ja, er wird
an alle möglichen Firmen vermietet.
Die Besitzer
sind Immobilienmenschen.
Die denken nur an Immobilien.
Dann kam Corona
und dann musste man schliessen.
Das sind
sieben verschiedene Pavillons.
In jedem
wird ein anderes Thema behandelt.
Z.B. Steinzeit oder Nazca,
wo wir hingehen.
Oder die Pyramiden in Mexiko.
Alle Texte, die du
im Kopfhörer hörst, stammen von mir.
Hatte er mal erfolgreich geöffnet?
- Sehr, bis zur blöden Coronazeit.
Als Aktionär hat Erich von Däniken
hier auch viel Geld verloren.
Der Park steht zum Verkauf.
Ob er einen Käufer findet und
jemals wieder seine Pforten öffnet,
steht in den Sternen.
Die Nazca-Show startet heute exklusiv
für uns und soll uns etwas zeigen,
was sonst angeblich
nie im Fernsehen zu sehen ist.
Die Wüstenregionen Nazca und Palpa
in Peru
sind bekannt
für hunderte grossflächige Bilder,
die aus dem Boden gescharrt wurden,
und sich dem Betrachter
meist nur aus der Luft erschliessen.
So weit erklärt man alles
auch der Öffentlichkeit.
Was laut von Däniken
seltener gezeigt wird,
sind die oft kilometerlangen
geometrischen Formen und Linien.
Gemäss Archäologen fanden auf
den Schaubildern einst Rituale statt,
die dann auch
von der Erde aus sichtbar waren.
Die Trapeze und Linien
sollen Prozessionswege gewesen sein.
Besonders prägnant: Ein Berg, der
wie absichtlich begradigt aussieht.
(Video) Erinnerungen an die Zukunft
werden geweckt.
Erinnerungen
an etwas Unverstandenes,
das einst war
und nach Verständnis schreit.
Jetzt ist die Show fertig.
Mein Vorschlag war,
dass da ein Mutterraumschiff war.
Das drehte im Orbit
und sie mussten auftanken.
Sie massen,
dass es in Nazca Rohstoffe gab.
Übrigens heute noch -
sehr gold- und mineralreich.
Ein kleines Zubringerflugzeug
ist also da gelandet.
Sie machten Bohrungen,
nahmen Proben und starteten wieder.
Die Eingeborenen
verstanden das nicht,
sahen aber die Linien von
der Landung des kleinen Fahrzeugs.
Weggeschleuderter Sand und Steine.
Die Eingeborenen sahen das:
"Das waren die Götter."
"Sie wollen,
dass wir Linien machen."
Also fingen die Eingeborenen an,
Linien zu ziehen.
Und das wurde zum Kult.
Das war mein Vorschlag.
Das wurde ja
schon gross angelegt erforscht.
Nur von archäologischer Seite.
Die Archäologenzunft
soll mir mal erklären,
warum eine Kultur vor Jahrtausenden
einen Berg flach macht.
Und mit welchen Mitteln.
Man will es nicht sehen.
Man ist zu borniert.
Das darf einfach nicht sein.
Yes.
"Zwei Dinge sind unendlich ..."
Albert Einstein:
"Zwei Dinge sind unendlich -
das Universum
und die menschliche Dummheit."
"Wobei ich bei Ersterem
nicht ganz sicher bin."
Woran arbeiten Sie gerade?
- An Buch Nummer 46.
Ob ich noch eines schreibe,
wage ich zu bezweifeln.
Inzwischen
bin ich über 88 Jahre alt.
Mein Verstand funktioniert,
Gott sei Dank.
Ich erinnere mich an alles.
Aber der Körper wird langsam müde.
Wie heisst das aktuelle Buch?
Der Arbeitstitel lautet
"Und sie waren doch da!".
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023